an incredible contestant on America's
Got Talent is dead just weeks before
getting his time in the spotlight I gave
my life to show you that I love you more
than you
no et has learned dr. Brandon Rogers was
involved in a car accident in Maryland
on Saturday he was taken to a local
hospital where he died on Sunday funeral
arrangements for the 29 year old are
currently being made a family member
tells ET quote what we want people to
remember most is his love of God and how
much he touched others his ability to
sing was a gift
it was Brandon's incredible voice that
landed him a spot on a GT producers were
reportedly blown away after seeing him
on Instagram covering the boys two men
hit on bended knee
[Music]
Oh even the band was impressed they
invited him on stage with them back in
January
[Music]
[Applause]
the boyband took to Instagram to comment
on the tragic news this week writing
even for the little time we knew you you
will be sorely missed
according to TMZ America's Got Talent
producers have not made a decision on
whether they will run Rogers episode it
was scheduled to air next month
[Music]